So today we are going to go through some of
the different testimonies that were given
not only yesterday but today in the Trump
impeachment [inaudible]
hurry and they are devastating, particularly
Gordon Sunderland's today.
But this is a good time to just sort of be
very real now that we are what like 25 hours
into the public testimony of this thing and
just all beyond the same page that if Democrats
can't make something happen, if they can't
get something from these hearings, it's going
to be extremely embarrassing and it may backfire
significantly.
And what I mean by that is the Mueller probe
happened behind closed doors.
There were almost no leaks.
It happened in private.
We went about our lives during the Mueller
probe and then we heard it was over and we
got the bar propaganda letter, which we immediately
knew was merely a propaganda letter.
And then the report came out and then molar
testified and then people could debate, okay,
what do we get from it?
What don't we get from from it?
But it was not an excruciating process into
which so much network TV time has been invested.
We have roughly 25 as of this.
As of right now, I think we're about 25 hours
in to the public hearings.
Uh, more today we had nearly 12 hours yesterday.
We've got another four to six hours tomorrow.
People are watching.
The ratings are actually good despite what
Devin Nunez likes to say, Oh, the ratings
are down, people are pot.
You're paying attention to this stuff even
though it is at the same time, boring in a
sense, even though it's extraordinarily important,
but it is monopolizing news television for
the greater part of every day.
And then after it's over, the news shows are
mostly analyzing what it is that took place.
The substance of it is damning to Trump in
a way that words almost can't encompass.
And we'll talk about that next inter, including
about Gordon Sunderland's testimony.
Clearly many people understood what was going
on was a trade, a quid pro quo, an attempt
at bribery and extorted act.
But is anything going to happen in terms of
impeachment itself?
62% of Trumpists say they will never turn
on Trump.
If Trump is, don't turn on Trump.
Republican senators won't turn on Trump.
So then the question of Dems getting something
becomes, can the hearings plus whatever commentary
Democrats can add actually shock people enough
about Donald Trump's brazen actions that it
swings public opinion against him and pushes
him out of office via losing reelection in
2020.
I don't know the answer to that.
On the one hand, half the country now wants
Trump removed, as I told you yesterday, based
on new Poland.
On the other hand, this is a lot of eggs in
the basket of public hearings.
Uh, and for a whole suite of reasons, I don't
know that it's going to go anywhere.
If it doesn't, I fear there will be a rebound
effect.
And it could be very embarrassing for Democrats.
Again, not because the facts don't support
impeachment with Gordon Sunderland's testimony
today, I don't know how anyone could argue
that this was not an explorative bribery,
quid pro quo.
But the problem is it's not that the hearings
are a waste of time.
They're actually the opposite.
They are so important and that's why we've
been covering all of them on the David Pakman
show YouTube channel live.
It's been long days here at the David Pakman
show, but because they will be needlessly
ridiculed if they don't get something out
of it for having taken over news television
for endless hour after hour after hour, week
after week after week and getting quote nothing.
Remember it's quote, nothing.
It could end up having the rebound effect
of helping Donald Trump secure reelection.
I don't want that to happen.
I fear that it will if we don't all make sure
that these hearings are seen for what they
are, which is extraordinarily damning.
Assessments of what Donald Trump and the people
around him have done.
Let's now get to yesterday
and today's hearings,